bullied by leftist activists disney
decided to step out of its role as just
a great family entertainment company
that we all love and into the role of a
radical political advocate and it's not
just moms and dads like you just heard
from fighting back but the employees of
disney as well so we sent our own
raymond arroyo down to disney about 12
miles from here to talk to some of the
fed up employees
do you believe that there's political
bias or at least political pressure from
within the company to conform to a
certain ideal absolutely i i to be
honest at this point i believe that
company has been hijacked by the left uh
the liberal left we are the silent
majority we go in and we are here to do
our job we do our job we take care of
the guests we don't bring politics into
uh the office disney made an even bigger
mistake and now listen to us we support
the bill because we're parents we're
grandparents and we want to protect our
children employees everywhere people who
have retired people who can't wait to
retire people who work in the company
right now in california here in orlando
all over from every segment of the
company they have reached out to me and
say thank you uh what's going on the
company is not right and thank you for
being a voice for us we need new
leadership our ceo bob chapin you know
he's supposed to be leading the company
not following the volk ma right and he's
the ceo as the ceo he has fiduciary duty
to the stockholders of this company that
means he has to protect their investment
protect their money and instead what did
he do he protect the feelings of a few
small minority workers in the walt
disney company jose castillo is only one
of 77 000 disney employees at this park
and 2 000 more are coming from the west
coast in fact florida incentivized the
move by giving disney
570 million dollars in tax cuts over the
next 20 years well now long time
employees are making their voices heard
and a lot of it in the past two years
has been heavy heavy heavy
against things to say not to say don't
hurt people's feelings um that you know
don't say he she ladies gentlemen you
know just very like you know basically
we have to be in fear of what we say now
the letter that went out to the disney
management asking for political
neutrality
these people said they don't feel
welcome in the company anymore in fact
they felt estranged from it
is that how you feel
absolutely that was that was how i felt
wanting to just come to work put our
heads down and do the work create the
magic and everything like that it became
increasingly harder to do i am deeply
saddened by what disney has chosen to
take their stand on
politically and with just their money in
general and where i've really seen the
company gone such a drastic change from
how i started at the company to where we
are now i mean you can clearly see the
magic is gone they've made it very clear
that conservative christian voices have
no place visiting their parks or working
at their parks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else